and there we would all stay hanging on
the words that would fall for my
grandmother's lip when she brought us
part of the enemy as though there had
been some uncertainty among the vast
number of possible invaders and then
soon after my grandfather would say I
can hear swans voice and indeed one
could tell him only by his voice before
it was difficult to make out his face
with its arch nose and green eyes under
a high forehead fringed with blond
almost red hair dressed in the Brussels
style because in the garden we used as
little light as possible so as not to
attract mosquitoes and I would slip away
as though not going for anything in
particular to tell them to bring out the
syrups my grandmother made a great point
thinking it nicer over there not being
allowed to seem anything out of the
ordinary and for visitors only although
if our younger man Misha Swann was very
much attracted attached to my
grandfather who had been a close friend
of swans father an excellent but
eccentric man in whom the least little
thing would it seemed often check the
flow of his spirits and divert the
current of his thoughts several times in
the course of a year I would hear my
grandfather tell the table the story
which never varied of the behavior of mr
Swan the elder on the death of his wife
by whose bedside he had watched day and
night my grandfather who had not seen
him for a long time hasten to join him
at the Swans family property on the
outskirts of Combray and managed to
entice him for a moment we been
profusely out of the room where she lay
dead so that he would not be present
when the body was laid in its coffin
they took a turn or two in the park
where there was a little sunshine
suddenly mr Swan seized my grandfather
by the arm and cried o my dear old
friend how fortunate we are to be
walking here together in such fine
weather don't you see how pretty they
are all these trees my ha thorns and my
new pond on which you have never
congratulated me you look down in the
dumps don't you feel this little breeze
whatever you may say it's good to be
alive all the same my dear I'm a day and
then abruptly the memory of his dead
wife returned to him and probably
thinking it too complicated
to inquire into how at such a time he
could have allowed himself to be carried
away by an impulse of happiness he
confided himself to a gesture that he
had habitually employed whenever any
perplexing question came into his mind
that is he passed his hand across his
forehead dried his eyes and wiped his
glasses and he could never be consoled
for the loss of his wife but used to say
to my grandfather doing it during the
two years by which he survived her it's
a funny thing now I very often think of
my poor wife but I cannot think of her
very much at any one time often but at a
little often but a little at a time like
poor old swan became one of my
grandfather's favorite phrases which he
would apply to all kinds of things and I
would have assumed that his father that
this father of swans had been a monster
of my grandfather whom I regardless a
better judge than myself and whose word
was my law and often led me in the long
run to pardon offences I would have been
inclined to dem had not gone on to
exclaim but after all he had a heart of
gold for many years and especially
before his marriage when Lucius wand
younger came often to see them at
Combray my great aunt and grandparents
never suspected that he had entirely
ceased to live in the kind of society
that his family had frequented or that
under the sort of incognito that the
same sorry that the name of Swan gave
him among us that they were harboring
with complete innocence of a family of
honest innkeepers who have in their
midst some distinguished bandits and
never know it one of the most elegant
members of the jockey club a particular
friend of the cult dipali and of the
Prince of Wales and one of the men most
sought after in the aristocratic world
of the foe Bell saw Germans our utter
ignorance of the brilliant part that
Swann was playing in the world of high
society was of course due in part to his
own reserve and discretion but also to
the fact that middle-class people in
those days took what was almost a Hindu
view of society which they held to
consist of sharply defined castes so
that everyone at his birth was found
himself called to that station in life
that his parents already occupied and
nothing except the chance of a brilliant
career or fortune
marriage could extract you from that
station or admit you to a superior cast
Misha Swan the father had been a
stockbroker and so young Swan found
himself emerged from life in a cast
where once fortune as in a list of
taxpayers varied between such and such
limits of income we knew the people with
whom his father had associated and so we
knew his own associates the people with
whom he was in a position to mix if he
knew other people besides those were
youthful acquaintances on whom the old
friends of the family like my relatives
shut their eyes all the more good
naturedly because Swann himself after
the death of his parents still came most
faithfully to see us but we would have
been ready to wager that the people
outside are quite in soon Swan knew were
of the sort to whom he would not have
dared to raise his hat that he'd met
them while he was walking with us had
there been such a thing as a
determination to apply to Swan a social
coefficient peculiar to himself a
distinct from all the other sons of
stockbrokers in his father's position
his coefficient would have been rather
lower than theirs because leading a very
simple life and having always had a
craze for antiques and pictures he now
lived and piled up his collection in an
old mansion that my grandmother longed
to visit but that stood on the quad air
along the neighborhood in which my
great-aunt thought it most degrading to
live are you really a connoisseur now
she would say to him I ask for your own
sake as you are likely to fake spawned
off on you by the dealers for she did
not in fact in doubt him with any
critical faculty and had no great
opinion of the intelligence of a man who
in conversation would avoid serious
topics and showed a very dull
preciseness not only when he gave us
kitchen recipes going into the most
minut details but even when my
grandmother's sisters were talking to
him about art when challenged by them to
give an opinion Oh to express his
admiration for some picture he would
remain almost impolitely silent and
would then make amends by furnishing if
he could some fact or other about the
museum in which the picture was hung
were the date at which it had been
painted
but as a rule he would content himself
with trying to amuse us by telling us
the story of his latest adventure and he
would have a new story for us on every
occasion with someone whom we ourselves
knew such as the calm brave pharmacist
or our cook or our coachman these
stories certainly used to make my
great-aunt laugh but she could never
tell whether that was on account of the
absurd parts which Swan invariably made
himself play in the adventures or of the
width that he showed in telling us of
them it is easy to see that you're a
real character mischa Swan as she was
the only member of our family who could
be described as a trifle coming she
would always take care to remark to
strangers when Swan was mentioned that
he could easily if he had wished to have
lived in the boulevard haussmann or the
Avenue des Lak God and that he was the
son of old Monsieur Swan who must have
left him four or five million francs but
that was a whim of it that it was a whim
of his a win which moreover she thought
was bound to muse other people so much
that in Paris when Misha Swan called on
New Year's Day bringing her a little
pachyderm a tall glass say she never
failed if there were guests in the room
to say to him well Mischa Swan do you
still live next door to the wine Depot
some has to be sure of not missing your
train when you go to Leo and she would
peep out of the corner of her eye of her
long Lorne y'all at the other visitors
but if anyone had suggested to my aunt
that this Swan who in his capacity as
the old as the son of old mr Swan was
fully qualified to be received by Nev
the upper middle class the most
respected notaries and lawyers of Paris
though he was perhaps a trifle inclined
to let this hereditary privilege go into
abeyance had an almost had had another
almost secret existence of a wholly
different kind that when he left our
house in Paris saying that he must go
home to bed he would no sooner have
turned the corner that he would stop
retrace his steps and be off to some
drawing room on whose like no
stockbroker or associative stockbrokers
had ever set eyes that would have seemed
to my aunt and as extraordinary as to a
woman of wider reading thought of being
herself
on terms of intimacy with aristes of
knowing that he would when he had
finished his conversation with her
plunged deep into the realms of Thetis
into an empire veiled from more lives in
which Virgil depicts him has been
received with open arms or to be content
with an image more likely to have
occurred to her for she had seen it
painted on the pains on the plates we'd
used for petty foie at Combray of having
had had having had to dinner with
Alibaba who as soon as he found himself
alone and observed would make his way
into the cave resplendent with its
unsuspected treasures